eine fläche von über 200 fußballfeldern
überflutet schätzungsweise mehr als 3000
häuser beschädigt 60 brücken zerstört
und 134 menschen sind gestorben
[Musik]
das alles ist ein langer passiert in der
fatalen flut nacht vor genau einem jahr
sind sie gefahren worden
nein
es war keiner hier keine polizei kein
feuerwerk ein signal nix nix
warum gab es hier und da zwar schon zum
beispiel von der feuerwehr wie man hier
sehen kann aber fest steht die warnungen
waren nicht ausreichend
sie haben offensichtlich nicht alle
menschen im alter erreicht was müssen
wir aus dieser katastrophe lernen um uns
für kommende hochwasser stürme
überschwemmungen oder dürren zu rüsten
wir kommen bei context wir haben im zdf
archiv nach erklärungen aus früheren
zeiten für aktuelle probleme ich bin
aminata berlin
[Musik]
flut im aartal drei dinge die wir lernen
müssen starten wir bei vermeintlich
alten instrumenten die im zweifel aber
leben retten können sirenen und
lautsprecher bei der flut im aartal
fehlten die sirenen selbst die feuerwehr
wurde vom hochwasser überrascht kein
mobilfunk kein digitalfunk und kaum
sirenen
zum einen sind die weggerissen worden
zum anderen hatten wir ab etwa 19 uhr 30
einen kompletten stromausfall hier in
der region und die augen tränen sind
auch nicht akut sofort das heißt dem
zeitpunkt konnten sie auch gar keine
sonne auslösen der beitrag beschreibt
gibt es diverse gründe warum die sirenen
in dieser nacht nicht losgegangen sind
ein zentraler ist an vielen orten gibt
es gar keine mehr oder sie sind veraltet
dabei waren sie mal zentraler
bestandteil des deutschen schutzkonzept
auch heute gibt es hierzulande noch so
etwas wie luft schutz
zu hören ist dies zweimal im jahr mit
dem gesamten bundesgebiet die sirenen
heulen ihre funktionstüchtigkeit zu
überprüfen
heute fehlen die sirenen an allen ecken
und enden deutschlands warum ein kurzer
blick zurück nach der wiedervereinigung
und dem zerfall der sowjetunion war
plötzlich die große gefahr eines kriegs
weckt und damit auch die notwendigkeit
für sie reden wie schlecht das netz
ausgebaut ist zeigte sich erstmals am
nationalen wahlen tag im september 2020
damals wollte die bundesregierung
eigentlich schauen ob die verschiedenen
wahn systeme funktionieren doch
vielerorts verwunderung es bleibt still
in münchen etwa der grund hier sind alle
sirenen längst abgebaut ich kann mich
daran auch sehr gut erinnern dass man
etwas erwartet hat und nichts kam
schreibt uns mal die kommentare wie er
das mitbekommen habt zumindest hat der
bund nach dem fehlgeschlagenen wahltag
ein förderprogramm in höhe von 88
millionen euro beschlossen um ein
flächendeckendes sie reden netz
aufzubauen und auch das aartal soll nach
dem hochwasser neue mit akkus
ausgestattetes reden bekommen
aufholbedarf gibt es aber auch in einem
ganz anderen preis um 11 uhr 17 meldet
die offizielle katastrophenschutz s-bahn
eine erste amtliche hochwasser warnung
für das ahrtal
130000 menschen leben im landkreis nur
22.000 haben die apple damit kommen wir
zum zweiten learning warnung über handys
müssen verlässlicher werden die flut im
ahrtal hat nämlich gezeigt dass die
wahren apps nina und kaplan nur bedingt
helfen beim nächsten katastrophenfall
soll alle telefone ihre besitzer und
besitzerinnen waren egal ob das handy
ein alter knochen ist in ruhe modus an
oder die wahl app installiert hat
deswegen über die bundesregierung nun
eine technik einsetzen die andere
staaten schon lange dementiert habe
[Musik]
die usa haben es
rumänien hat es und in den niederlanden
weiß letzte woche auch nützlich gemeint
ist cell broadcast für deutsche etwa
funkzellen rundfunk mensch und tiere
sind gewarnt die supporters technik
funktioniert vereinfacht gesagt so jedes
handy muss sich mit einer funkzelle
verbinden wenn es ihn empfangen zu einem
handy netz herstellen will laut eine
gefahr in einem bestimmten gebiet können
behörden eine warnung an alle geräte
schicken die sich mit einer bestimmten
funktion verbunden haben beim nächsten
wahltag im september diesen jahres soll
diese technik zum ersten mal in
deutschland erprobt werden kommen wir
zum dritten und letzten punkt den er aus
der flutkatastrophe
2021 mitnehmen sollten es ist nicht die
erste flutkatastrophe in deutschland
haben behörden und politik aus der
vergangenheit zu wenig gelernt es gibt
feuerwehr technisches hilfswerk
katastrophenstäbe in den ländern sogar
ein bundesamt für katastrophenschutz
das alles war offenbar zu wenig im
katastrophenfall müssen die
zuständigkeiten klar geregelt sein ein
problem das in deutschland schon lange
besteht quasi negative tradition hat
brennende wälder haushohe flammen die
brandkatastrophe in der lüneburger heide
vor zwei jahren erkenntnis aus dieser
katastrophe die zersplitterung der
hilfskräfte und die unklarheit der
zuständigkeiten sind eine gefährliche
schwäche bei der bekämpfung von
katastrophen
allein die koordination der vielen
ehrenamtlichen organisation ist eine
ziemliche herausforderung aber
der katastrophenschutz ist eine
wesentliche aufgabe des zivilschutzes
für den zivilschutz und damit auch für
den katastrophenschutz ist im
verteidigungsfall nur der bund zuständig
normalerweise jedoch ist der
katastrophenschutz im gegensatz zu den
übrigen aufgaben des zivilschutzes
ausschließlich ländersache
ich glaube dass wir mit der organisation
des bevölkerungs und katastrophenschutz
ist nach wie vor richtig aufgestellt
sind in deutschland also noch mal
langsam zivilschutz heißt schutz der
bevölkerung in kriegszeiten der
katastrophenschutz ist der schutz beim
nichtmilitärischen notfällen wie etwa
bei unwetter oder unfällen für letztere
sind die länder zuständig dort aber
managen gemeinden und kreise das
geschehen der bund wiederum darf nur
unterstützen wenn die länder ihn darum
bitten übrigens falls sie mehr darüber
erfahren wollt wie das mit dem
katastrophen und zivilschutz in den
siebzigern ablief schaut doch mal in der
zdf mediathek vorbei dort haben wir
einen beitrag aus dem jahr 1977 in
voller länge für euch hochgeladen
die flutkatastrophe vor allem jahr hat
über 180 todesopfer gefordert
134 davon entlang der aa
das reh netz wieder neu aufbauen die
cell broadcast technik einführen und
zuständigkeiten klarer regeln diese drei
learnings sollten die
entscheidungsträger und trägerin aus der
flutkatastrophe im aartal mitnehmen
damit wir künftig besser vorbereitet
sind insgesamt müssen wir uns alle aber
stärker an den gedanken gewöhnen das
unwetter katastrophen kommen können und
diese durch den menschengemachten
klimawandel schlimmer sein könnten als
alles was wir bislang erfahren haben ich
denke einfach dass es hier im dorf
vielleicht auch nicht so verbreitet hat
oder vielleicht auch nicht so ernst
genommen weil sie die ganzen leute die
haben ja sämtliche hochwasser schon
mitgemacht und das ist immer in
anführungszeichen gut gegangen dass wir
sicher sind und dass unser wohlstand
sicher ist ist leider keine
selbstverständlichkeit mehr diese
mentale vorbereitung sollte aber
einhergehen mit einer ganz praktischen
vorbereitung dem schutz unserer häuser
und wohnung und allem was für uns
wichtig und wertvoll ist soweit möglich
im sächsischen grimma das in den letzten
20 jahren gleich zweimal von heftigen
hochwasser betroffen waren haben sie
diese lektion verinnerlicht was auf den
ersten blick wie eine mauer aussieht ist
die modernste hochwasserschutzanlage der
welt errichtet nach der jahrhundertflut
2002 in einer höhe bis zu acht metern
steht die mulde damals in der
historischen altstadt 800 häuser werden
zerstört oder unbewohnbar 2013 dann die
nächste flut einmal im jahr probt die
feuerwehr den verschluss der 78 tonnen
schweren fluten anderthalb stunden
dauert das aber nicht nur mauern gehört
zu einem wirksamen hochwasserschutz
auch sollten wir unsere städte und
dörfer an die veränderten
klimabedingungen anpassen dürfen die
flächen nicht komplett versiegeln und
sollten raum für migration schaffen
diese ganzen prophylaktischen maßnahmen
werden eine menge geld kosten die
innenminister und innenministerien der
länder forderten den bund im nun dazu
auf zehn milliarden euro in den nächsten
zehn jahren in den katastrophenschutz zu
investieren doch es wird mehr kosten
wenn wir gar nichts tun zum vergleich
der wiederaufbau für die vom hochwasser
2021 betroffenen regionen beträgt 30
milliarden euro
also dreimal so viel wie der bund in den
nächsten zehn jahren in den
katastrophenschutz investieren soll das
soll nicht heißen dass die hilfsgelder
flut betroffene nicht es sind sie wären
aber vorsorge ist billiger und rettet im
zweifel lieber wir haben jetzt so ein
fenster in dem wir etwas erreichen
können bevor irgendwann vielleicht
wieder so eine katastrophe demenz
einsetzt und dann brauchen wir auch eben
hier entsprechende investitionen wenn
ihr mehr vom kontext sehen wollt dann
schaut auch hier vorbei bei diesem video
frage ich mich was die politik aus ihren
fehlern während der korona pandemie
gelernt und hier gibt es eine weitere
aufarbeitung zur flutkatastrophe im art
von meinen kolleginnen von zdf zoom und
hier könnt ihr die glocke aktivieren
damit ihr kein video verpasst